Hi, everybody.
How are you all doing today?
Jump up and down a few things.
Stretch a little bit.
High-five the person to your right because
you can.
My name is Adam Miller.
This is OpenJS.
This is between you and me, we won't tell
the panellists, how many people know what
the JS Foundations do, and interact with them
a lot and should be up here on this panel?
I see a few hands.
Who knows that the foundations exist and kind
of know what they do but really ... couldn't
give a talk on it or be on the panel here.
Here is, ""We're talking about foundations?
We're talking about open source, right, why
is there a foundation involved?""
We've done a lot of work recent to merge together
the Node Foundation, and the JavaScript Foundation
into the OpenJS Foundation.
It's been a ten-month process or more.
We are really excited to share with you what
we've been doing.
There's an awesome panel of people here who
are have been rocking it on the foundation
formation side, and I guess we will about
down the line and do intros here.
>> You have a standalone full-screen experience
from looks like any other app on the iPhone.
So it's basically a PWA.
Then you have - feature phones, I have this
Nokia here with me, feature phones, non-touch,
they're supporting PWAs.
But it's not just on mobile.
On desktop you can go and install Trivago,
Tinder, by the way, and you have a - that
works on Windows, Chromebook, Mac and Linux.
You can open more PWAs at the same time.
We have the properly, we just need to create
really, really good experiences, and today,
let's say that I can say that maybe half of
the PWA s out there on R offering a good experience.
The other half are away for offering a competition
like the native apps, and so we will try to
see why, and
what we can do today to improve that experience.
So, talking about the app cycle, okay?
So because we are creating apps, not just
websites that will appear in the browser.
So, when you open a PWA, so if the d Platform.
I'm Google's representative as a platinum
member board representative and the vice-chair
of the Open JS Foundation.
Before that, I was the elected representative
on the board prior to the merger in the original
structure of the node.js Foundation.
There were three board seats that are community
members.
Tracy had one of them, and I was representing
the other group.
>> I'm Adam Miller.
In the daytime, I work on LinkedIn.
We can't talk to the future of the organisation
without looking to the past.
I would like to get a tl;dr on the node Node
Foundation and the JavaScript Foundation.
>> So a the although of people may not realise
that the JavaScript community has had a foundation
working on behalf of open-source projects
for a long time.
Back in the mid-2000s, we had the jQuery project
that got wildly popular and we made a foundation
for jQuery that added projects over time which
later merged with what was the Dojo Foundation
which had a handful of projects itself and
just kind of that was about three or four
years ago, and so that was when we became
the JS Foundation, and we've been rocking
along behind the scenes for quite some time.
>> And the Node JS Foundation was formed in
2015 to provide a future place where a number
of different groups within the node community
could come together and work on figuring out
how to move things forward into the future.
There was a few sort of key things that were
important, which I think we will see flow
through so what we see in the OpenJS Foundation
as well as that neutrality, if they contribute,
they have the tools and the access that they
need to make things happen.
That is something we will see reflected in
what we talk about in the OpenJS Foundation
as well.
In September 15, we -
we've seen consistent and reliable releases
ever since then.
I think it's a good sign of the stability
and the ability for everybody to get in in
work together on that front.
>> Yes, I know early on when it was just in
early discussions about the two foundations
merging, there was a good bit of uncertainty
about whether it should happen, whether it
was the right time to do it.
I know a lot of you feel that a lot of those
concerns early on, I was hoping you could
answer maybe why not, and why merge?
>> Can you repeat that one more time really
quickly?
>> Why are we merging now and why - what is
the reason for the merge?
>> It's been a long couple of days!
So there are a number of different reasons
to consider merging foundations.
If you go and look at the bylaws of the foundation
itself, right in there, we claim that we want
to be a centre of gravity for the JavaScript
ecosystem.
Prior to there being one primary foundation,
it wasn't really clear.
And it's hard because Node was the main project
in the node.js Foundation, and joining something
bigger means giving some stuff up, and there's
an anecdote I really like.
When I kind of started getting into the node.js
ecosystem, when I had just moved to California,
I got - I got a free ticket to go to a conference
called Node Summit.
This was right around the time of the fork,
and they were talking about merging, and I
have no shame, so I walked right up to Scott
Hammond at the time the CEO of Joyant and
asked him why would you put Node?
A foundation - in a foundation?
He said it's better to have a smaller piece
of a bigger pie.
To me, when I think about these foundations,
and we just had our summit recently which
was fantastic, and so many new faces in the
room that weren't there before, we just massively
expanded the scope of the work that we can
do, who we can work with, how we can work
with them.
We get to revisit all of these kind of preconceived
notions when Node first went in the foundation,
it was very reactive.
We had things that we needed to protect and
fix and now we can be proactive and start
thinking about what we want to build.
>> It made me think we all know we can accomplish
a lot more than we could on our own as an
individual, so it's the same thing for a larger
foundation.
>> And sort of wearing the Node hat, there
was a lot of scepticism when we were talking
about a merger.
And not - I wouldn't necessarily say it was
balanced.
There was a lot from the Node side, and, again,
it was because we had experience going through
I think a pretty tumultuous foundation formation
not too many years ago, and Node was finally
feeling like a stable place sort of firing
on all cylinders, we were working together
in the community, and the TSC, but I think
as part of that, we ended up seeing how bringing
in the up stream components in the JS ecosystem,
that, like, we were stronger when we were
doing that together, and so by focusing on
these sorts of things that we had already
learned, transparency, including not - not
just including - giving autonomy to the project
members so they could run and host these meetings,
we ran weekly meetings when it came to the
merger discussion and planning so whatever
wanted to drive the planning from particular
initiative phases of making this merger happen,
it was only going to happen if people showed
up and did the work, and that is from the
project side, not from the board side.
>> Yes, I will add that on the .just Foundation
side, we immediately you a the benefit of
possibly merging with the Node ecosystem because
all of our projects really rely on Node.
At the same time, there was fear and uncertainty
because there was a lot of historical drama,
and energy from the community which may be
disruptive to what was otherwise fairly stability
projects.
So, you know, with that optimism, but cautious
optimism in mind, everybody got really excited
about the possibility of collaborating more
closely with their peers on the Node side
through one umbrella, and I think that's kind
of what put us over the edge.
>> And one of the things that building on
what both Tracy and Jory was saying, from
the get-go, we approached this from an egalitarian
mind set.
We made the doors open, like we tried to be
hyper inclusive as much as possible.
If you are a member or a committer, and even
then we weren't that picky, like, if you wanted
to show up to those meetings and you wasn't
being disruptive, you had a voice and a seat
at the table, and were participating.
I think that was really important to make
sure that this could be successful.
>> I was going to say, we looked at the governance
for a number of the different projects, for
the Node Foundation, Kubernetes, and I'm happy
that we ended up with something that is the
most, has the most opportunity, and hopefully
the best place where people will want to come
and will attract a lot of good people through
that.
I'm happy by looking at that, we ended up
with that open and really nice governance.
>> I think in all of this drives home the
value of this work is always project-driven,
and that's the point of the foundation, is
to help empower and give autonomy to the projects,
and get sort of the crap out of the way for
them to be able to do their good work.
>> I think what I've heard on that front is
we talk about great projects and the focus
will be on those great projects, not the foundation
itself.
>> So let's dig into some of that nitty-gritty.
Almost everybody in the room here is an engineer,
and I have always held the opinion that governance
is just coding but with words!
It's really what it has felt like over the
past ten months, and we have a visual aid
here as we talk about it.
Let's dive into some of the more nitty-gritty
details here of under the hood of what is
kind of making this foundation, new foundation
tick, and we can talk about some of the back
story, and reasoning behind these sections
of the foundation.
Yes, so, I mean, let's take it from the top
and go OpenJS board and talk about their functionality.
>> To start out with, I talked about the governance.
We have multiple levels so there are observers.
Any who wants to can come up and participate
in the meetings.
We want to get as many different ideas to
come to the best answers.
We have regular members who can actually,
people who in my mind who said I'm making
a commitment to be involved regularly and
they can they can be recognised for that.
Again, both observers and regular members
are involved in all of the work that goes
on.
And then finally, we have voting members where
in the rare cases where we need to actually
have a vote on something, it's that subset
who will do that vote.
Now, our experience in the Node project at
least has been that votes are very rare, we
follow a consensus-seeking approach, and really
it's going to be all of those members who
have ownership and who push things forward,
and so it should not really matter which level
you're in, but we have just to have the different
levels for the contingencies.
>> One thing that I can add, a mantra I would
tell myself, was that we wanted to create
structures and hierarchies of responsibility
rather than power.
So there isn't fundamentally a major power
balance between any of the members of the
any of the projects, being a voting member
just means you're more responsible.
You need to be showing up.
You need to make sure that things are getting
finished but you just don't get to shut down
another person's voice because you have that
responsibility.
>> The governance is really written so that
all the responsibilities of the CPC are the
responsibilities of all the members as opposed
to anybody in particular.
>> I want to talk a little bit about the projects
if we can, the staging, because I think for
me, this was a big bringing all JS Foundation
projects on board, and important they had
a voice in the project, and where they were
going to derive value and get value and services
from the organisation, so we came up with
this proposal that was loosely based on the
CNCF model of impact projects, growth-stage
projects, and what is not pictured here is
there a project which we have six projects
that we deemed, and the projects themselves
opted into this stage, functionally complete.
We recognised and thanked them for their contribution
they made to the comment but we're not really
encouraging people to go and contribute to
those projects or adopt those projects now.
We have five impact projects which are sort
of the projects that are a real kind of need
to have some resources and support on a very
active basis from the foundation.
They're used heavily in enterprise, and they
need that backing.
We have six growth projects and that stage
is for projects that have a specific objective
in mind, like there is a goal.
I need, I want to grow my contributor base.
I want to increase the number of implementations.
I want to put on an Yvette, or something like
that.
They have some specific goal for which they
need extra resources from the foundation for
a short period of time, growth stages for
those projects, and then we have 15 projects
that are projects that are fine, they're kind
of doing their thing, their resource needs
are pretty set, and we don't have to do too
much to support that.
>> One thing I can add from the At Large is
the Node Foundation, that was the only project.
That was half true.
It had attempted an incubation programme to
bring for projects in.
I personally, and I can't speak for how other
people feel, I don't feel that programme was
successful.
While we were merging, we have to make sure
that all projects are accounted for, and both
... and Express primarily wanted to continue
operating the way that they were, to be able
to not to have anything day-to-day change,
and perhaps have a bit of a better idea of
what resources were available to them such
as CI, or legal counsel, or PR and marketing
in case they needed it, but they mostly didn't
want anything to change.
By coming in as an At Large projects, these
two projects mostly on rails doing their own
thing, as far as I know, and I'm saying this
because we haven't heard anything from them,
it seems like everything's going fine, and
there's been pretty much no change day-to-day,
and so to me, I see a lot of these projects
as you do your thing the way you want to do
your thing, and we are here to support you
when you need it, and one of the really big
things I think we will want to be doing in
the near future is codefying and making it
far clearer what resources are available,
how to get access to those resources, and
how to create programmes for new resources
if they're not available yet.
>> I think we're better set up now to deal
with and cope with the different requirements
or aspirations that each project will have
as opposed to being part of the node.js Foundation
where you're a small part of a bigger project.
>> Do you want to talk about the membership
structure and how representation works at
the layer above the CPC?
>> Sorry, can you repeat that?
>> Do - I would love to hear more about the
membership structure and how the CPC interacts
with the rest of the org a little bit.
>> I think, Adam, let me know, you're asking
about how is the CPC formed and what is the
structure of the foundation on the community
side?
>> Yes.
>> I will start.
One thing that is really important, and this
is the only thing I really wanted to say,
is that the board which we are seeing over
on the left-hand side, which is made up of
a number of different members from corporate
entities, as well as as well as three three
community members right now, it is three,
it will go down to two soon, there is governance
- grab me, I will explain - but that group
is responsible for the things that you see
listed there.
They do not have authority over anything else.
The rest of the day-to-day operations of the
foundation that you see under the Cross Project
Council As well as the technical governance
of project is completely air gapped.
The boards and projects can work together
on things.
It doesn't mean that we are not partners.
But what it does mean is that the foundation
cannot install people into a project.
>> I think a good example here I can provide
is what happens if a code of conduct violation
happens with someone on leadership in one
of the projects?
What one would hope is that a project would
be able to manage that conflict themselves
and resolve it.
It's really hard to have to enforce those
policies on someone that you've worked with
for years, that you've seen work really hard,
but that you're seeing disagreements on.
So, you know, by experience, we've seen this
sort of happen that you could end up having
it saying like, board, we need you to provide
an answer because we don't really know what
to do here, and we know you have experience
at it.
The board, instead of saying, okay, you're
going to do this thing, it's instead saying
we are going to help you provide resources,
and we're going to work with you together
to figure this out, but ultimately, you're
responsible for this work.
We just want to be here to guide you and provide
the monetary resources, the legal resources,
to help resolve that together, and hopefully
we will be better for that in the long run.
>> Taking on from the board participation,
we then have voting members which are elected.
We have two from the impact project.
It's up to the project to decide how they
want to elect those representatives.
We also have two which represent all of the
non-impact projects, although this year, as
a bootstrap, we accepted everybody who wanted
to participate at that level into the CPC
which is really great because we want to kick
off with as many people as we can in helping
to move things forward.
Then we actually can have an additional two
voting members who are elected from the regular
members.
If we see some people who haven't been elected
by an individual project but are doing a lot
of work and helping to move the CPC work forward,
they can be elected as voting members Intel.
>> Thank you.
Coming up on time here.
So I just want to go rapid-fire.
Starting with Myles.
If people leave here with one takeaway, from
this panel, what would you like it to be?
>> You don't have to do this alone.
>> Oh.
Succinct.
I like it!
Applause for that!
[Applause].
>> So I think I'm really excited to see how
we are going to - again, as Myles said, there's
excitement from the summit this week, prior
to JSConf EU, excited to seeing these guys
saying we are excited, we didn't know there
is a possibility here.
Taking the work we've done in Node and talk
to other people in the groups in the ecosystem,
or in the foundation, to get to work together
on these things, it's exciting to see the
opportunity that we have now in JavaScript
to be able to work together on this stuff,
even from helping more on the standards side.
>> For me, it's all about new opportunities,
and that I see a lot more new opportunities
for us to collaborate together, to have a
greater impact across projects, and to achieve
bigger things.
We have an opportunity to achieve things we
wouldn't be able to achieve on our own, it's
about new opportunities across all of the
different aspects.
>> I have, like, 37 things I would like to
share with people, but bearing in mind, that
we have a minute and a half left, I think
the first thing that I would like for you
all to take away is that there is a lot of
opportunity for you to give impact and what
services the Open JS Foundation provides to
your projects, and you can follow our work
on the Open JS Foundation organisation, bootstrap,
called the Cross Project Council repo now.
If you have an idea for something that would
be helpful to you as a member of one of our
projects, or as a potential member of one
of our projects, write a proposal or open
an issue on that, and start following along
with our meetings and that sort of thing on
YouTube and our weekly meetings there.
We have a great new email list you can start
to receiving these weekly emails from us that
sort of summarises like what is going on,
we have JS Foundation Slack Channel, so there
is a lot of opportunities to start having
these conversations together, and you can
make a difference.
You can come, and I can't wait to see you
there.
>> Wonderful, I just want to say I saw a lot
of this collaboration between projects starting
at the most recent collaborators summit which
was right before this conference.
We got people from across the new open JS
Foundation together.
It was historically a Node event but the conversations
that actually happened in the hallway and
in talks are things that I could only dream
about.
We build amazing things on the internet together,
we build amazing things with JavaScript together,
and like Myles put it, we don't have to do
it alone, and we do it better together.
So, definitely go and get involved.
We are up on GitHub.
You can go to the website.
Thank you all for coming to this panel.
[Applause].